- Attends minute, là.enenenenen?
- Roxa Bru Bruneau, votre succès
ne cessera de m'étonner.
Vous êtes une vraie rockstar,
trtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtn
et au Centre Bell.- Oui.
- Et vous êtes parti d'un garage
à Saint-Philippe, en Montérégie.
ROXANE BRUNEAU, chanteuse
- Écoute... Je sais pas
comment je le vis, là.
De un, je suis vraiment mêlée,
parce que tu arrêtes pas de dire
"vous" depuis tout à l'heure.
On peut-tu dire "tu"?
(rires)
Je pense que je le vis bien,
je le vis mieux. Quand ça a
vraiment décoln n n n n n n n ne
en parle", c'était des grosses
crises de panique chez Walmart,
parce que, là, le monde
me rec
touchait, le monde me parlait.
Moi, j'étais habituée
à mon petit crowd sur Internet
qui me suivait depuis un certain
temps. Là, ça va mieux, j'ai
apprivoisé d d d d d d d d d d ,
c'était plus compliqué, là.
♪ Je suis partout
et nulle part à la fois ♪
- Lorsqu'on tape "Roxane
Bruneau" sur Google, on voénénée
certains fans venaient sonner
chez toi. Comment tu as vécu
ce déménagement-là? C'est
quand même une paiaiaiaiaiaiaiÇ,
c'est pas de la bienveillance.
T'sais, c'est ça. Ça, c'est
un infime pourcentage de ce que
j'ai déménagé parce que, là,
il y avait beaucoup de monde
qui savait où j'habitais,
qui venait sonner chez nous.
C'est arrivé trois fois,
quatre fois. C'était peut-être
Ça fait que, moi, j'ai déménagé
aussi parce que c'était
le temps, là, c'était pas'a'a'a.
C'était juste la cerisequi a fa.
- Ça a dû être effrayant, là,
dormir la nuit, puis...
- Bien, j'avais pas constamment
peur, mais je dormais avec
un petit bâton de golf.
(Ils éclatent de rire.)
- Sérieusement?
- Oui, puis non, là.
J'avais un sac de golf.
♪ Je voulais rien savoir
d'un 9 à 5 ♪
♪ Je voulais la gloire
- La carrière et la vie
de Roxane Bruneaesest racontée
dans tes chansons. Je pense à
"J'suis pas stressée".
l'emploi, pour vivre le grand
rêve. Ça a pris beaucoup
de courage. À quel moment
pourquoi faire ce choix-là?
- Bien, écoute, j'haïssais
ma job, là. T'sais, moi,tététét,
ça fait que je travaillais
dans une pizzeria. Après ça,
j'ai travaillé dans un centrea s
pour moi qui pouvait me faire...
Il y avait rien d'artistique
dans tout ça, t'sais, même si
je plaçais les pepperonis
de façon comique une fois
de temps en MaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMx
oui et non, parce que
j'avais quand même un producteur
qui me disait : "C'est beau, là.
Tu
J'étais comme : "Là, tu es-tu
sûr de ce que tu me dis, là?
Parce que moi, j'ai des affaires
à payer!" Il y a quand même
Ça va être correct.
(avec une voix rauque):
On en a fait une autre année
sur les internets, les jeunes!
- Moi, en rétrospecte e e e e ex
la Roxane Bruneau, l'humoriste
sur Internet. isis il y a
un talent certain, il y a
un don pour écrire des blagues.
- Bien, mo
(rire)
- Ilieient d'où, ce talent-là?
- Depuis que je suis toute
petite... Depuis que je suis
de l'impro puis du théâtre.
Puis... je sais pas.
J'ai vraiment commencé sur
Internet de même. Ça fait que
c'est comme si j'avais faitT'sa,
il rode son stock,
il va dans des bars,
puis il réécrit, puis...
Moi, je l'ai fait sur Internet
en faisant des vidéos, puis
en me disant : "Ah, ça, c'est
moins drôle, c'est moins bon.
moins drôle, c'popopopopopopopÇt
que j'ai fait mes classes
chez nous, falalement.
♪ C'est sûr que
je dois être en amour ♪
- Premieieieieieieieieieieieiei:
"Des petits bouts de moi"
avec au compteur 1mimillions
de visionnements.
Et c'est une vidéo qui fait
du bien, parce qu'elle elle met
entre deux femmes.
- Oui.
- Çauaussi, pour vous,
c'est important de parler
de ce thème-là, de libérer
une certaine parole?
de ça, de la fille pour qui
c'est important, mais c'était
juste naturel. J'ai... Il y a
même pas... J'étais très, très
jeune et très naïve au début.
Ça, ça a ét
C'est vraiment... pas de budget,
il y a pas personne.
J'étais comme : OK, il faut que
c'est tous de mes amis.
Personne n'a été payé.
Il y avait pas d'éclairagiste,
À la... le pouce, là, t'sais,
avec mon téléphonePuPuis,
c'était même pas dans le but
de : Je veux montrer deux femmes
qui  m m m m m m m m m m m m m .
♪ J'vais faire les choses
àà ma manière ♪
- Ce que je trouve super
intéressant, c'est que, oui,
au iPhone. Le deuxième album a
été enregistré dans une douche.
Je pense que c'est un message
pour les jeunes qui ont
que tout est possible finalement
en 2022.
- Oui. Je pense qu'avec
Internet, là, puis tous
tu peux juste te filmer
dix secondes, mettre ç
sur TikTok, puis t'sais,
s'il y a vraiment... si tu as
si quelqu'un te remarque...
Moi, c'est ça c'c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a remarqué sur Internet
puis qui m'a appelé, là, puis...
(rire)
Ça étété rapide.
- Cette semaine, tu vas sortir
deux chansons en exclusivité
- Oui.
- - Bien, tu sais, ça a sorti
cette semaine, il y a
des artistes qui critiquents s x
de musique en continu, en disant
que ça va tuer la musique
québécoise, parce que ça paie
pas assez de redevances.
très chaud. Qu'en penses-tu?
- Ah, c'est toujours...
J'ai toujours de la misère
avec ce genre de question-là.
C'est tough de se prononcer,
parce que je trouve que
je suis la pire pour parler
Parce que, moi, j'ai pas
justcecette plateforme-là,
tu comprends? Mes tounes,
elles jouent à la radio,
sur YouTube, ça fait que
je me verrais mal commencer
à faire : Ah! ça a pas
de bon sens!" Parce que
puis ils vont faire :
Ah, toi, là! La privilééeée,
tu veux-tu, bien, là?"
Ça fait que c'est pour ça que...
sauf que, moi, en ce moment,
je peux pas me pinindre.
- Roxane Bruneau, continue de
faire les choses à ta manière.
- Merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue. rcrci.
♪ Faire les choses
À ta manière